[Music]
we came on a good night
just weed is sticky like pick you get
him Fang and his cousin Nicky Nicky
Ricky and his cousin Nicky I'm talking
about
you
[Music]
like I said [__] icky Dickie and his
cousin Nikki uncle Joey's here more than
1940-something like dick and call me
shorty you follow me it's a beautiful
day to be alive I'm happy you made it
my main man Lisa ATS in the house
Alvarado is on his way and it's another
fun-filled evening
you're probably watching the Golden
Globes what is he wearing who gives a
[__] it's what you're worrying that
matters you know better yet it's what
she's worried if she's got clothes on
you [__] up she better be sitting
there with a bikini than sit up and I'm
talking about the Church of what's
happening you're coming to you directly
look at this weed we got tonight your
mother [__] this you tuned in tonight
that is just this weed is just
spectacular first of all they came in a
rec container with no label you know
what that means somebody's dying and who
did you see while these things they seen
the black cat look at this we thought
sticky icky dry I took one bong hit I'm
already feeling [__] Martians I feel
like a Scientologist [__] I'm saying
let's do another bong you hear get your
[__] together
if you're under 19 hang up now I can't
have your little young [__] don't
do homework go with a hat with a
propeller some [__]
[Music]
Joey what's with that little [__] [__]
blows look I know I'm sorry
I'm slipping I'm saying
[Music]
oh here we go that's a little better but
not really you came on a good night
we're gonna start with one of these 200
milligrams cobby chew and then we're
gonna drop a couple [__] decals
and transmission fluid
you know us and then look at this we're
gonna go light on the aperitif tonight a
few stars of death just to get the blood
going and I'm saying gotta get the blood
gone after the baby's workout today
after the baby's birthday party I went I
did a couple kettlebells I jump some
rope I hit the bag I did some situps
and now it's Miller time [__] who's
counting here well you're mathematician
is no need to count just eat [__]
and you get one with a [__] tail
who's better than you look at this you
know what this is gonna do to you
twinkle twinkle little star you don't
this dusty when they connect it like
that visit you got to that's 250 and
then you got an avatar hanging like a
[__] Mouse you understand me we're
going deep I told you but on the [__]
cape uncle Joey is coming into your
[__] living room Richard what's with
this Ruffin Superman had to the lady cut
it too [__] short in the back and
long in the front that Club is the bald
spot I don't give a [__] about the bald
spot all I give a [__] about is seeing
the devil and hanging out with you
contracting let's do another bond yep
this is good [__] weed dawg
you don't have to go oh just smoke my
nuts let's do a bond and call it even
right we're here but we're in the tunnel
of death you understand me
[Music]
I'm trying to look for the [__] poker
here to get this party started right how
are you good to see both of me can I get
you anything a Danish a cup of coffee go
[__] yourself you get nothing you get
nothing but [__] bong videos
[Music]
I love smoking dope with you PT no
medical marijuana as they say whatever
dope Oh No
get him Sam now the people get pissed
off at me Joey you gotta stop it's
medicine I know it's [__] medicine if
not able to stab the [__] 18
years ago I know it's medicine
[__]
but for me I like to see the devil with
it [__] you hurt me through my soul oh
oh the great weekend Green Bay advance
over the [__] Giants what else
happened Pittsburgh one you know this is
just a hell of a [__] weekend here
but you're lucky here tonight you're
gonna have the best kettle bell [__]
master cattle jitsu kettle bells cattle
[__] whatever the [__] you want tonight
it's gonna happen everybody's looking to
get in shape everybody's looking to
start the new year off with a [__]
bang I brought that for you tonight talk
something never mind the weed and the
edibles
we brought kettle cops sometimes you
wanna put you want to give some woman
some kettle [__] and [__] that's a real
thing dog dog you do you do 200 swings
in ten minutes give just a protein shake
and you look for a victim she ain't
walkin if you're real shame walking
testosterone-y we hear that's yours the
[__] you think we're running a charity
[__] that's yours
[Music]
we don't do that [__] just go check it
we don't want we don't want nobody to
know you're here in case you have a
heart attack okay sleep dies or
something you've never did a podcast
that here you go does it check then Oh
check then [__] that [__]
check yeah no [__] stabbed in the
neck [__] check then look at this
[__] profess this is transmission bullet
this is what the devil sent down to
spread the word look at smell this smell
this this is an animal call look look at
the grease coming on oh Jesus Christ
it's transmission fluid
oh yeah this should eat one of these
they got a call nine-one-one you won't
be able to stop doing swings you just be
sitting there swinging like a [__]
nut I'll make you lose nine pounds in
one night to one of these [__] things
you'll call me the next day go Joey I
lost nine pounds you're a [__] genius
you understand me oh this is the kettle
[__] program just do swings until you
pass the [__] out don't worry nutritious
delicious and I'm ready for the [__]
night now and so are you you sim saying
uncle Joey
there's no mishaps here there's nothing
but bong hits [__] Puerto Ricans
kettlebells we do it all we cover the
whole [__] spectrum you understand me
but it's that time we're ready for a
bong of death boys this [__] weed
this [__] weed is so good I went over
to get some edibles and one of the
Russians came out from the back he was
glowing in the dark he got he was there
when they [__] broke that [__]
thing and Russia was that when they were
waiting on line for toilet paper
Chernobyl that's his name Louie Ginobili
this [__] came out with that red
container I knew was no good his hands
were all missing his fingers even talked
to the Yakuza and missing fingers
Japanese guys they serve you at [__]
Benihana no he wasn't no he wasn't no
Yakuza boy he was here you go [__]
we're gonna beat the Bangkok today
[Music]
that's the man helps you find things
there we go
we [__] around Lisa at taking that to
the next level here my teeth taste this
lis this is the [__] that [__] Hitler
grew in Auschwitz this is the [__] right
here oh yeah look at this beautiful
[__] beautiful that's the best weed I
smoked on a few weeks there right there
yeah it's called Mickey Mouse
[Music]
[__] yeah that's what we do are people
waiting to play games I'm so high we
don't do we don't even get [__] high
warm you understand me look at those
eyeballs it was beautiful [__] I look at
that resume yeah yeah that's dirty is a
smoking reefer right there you can't
beat that [__] that's right I'm a
loser but who gives a [__] jack I did it
my way like Sinatra
we want to do what do you want to do you
want to [__] around do you want to do
bondage with Uncle Joe you want to [__]
around we'll call you other buddies with
the other podcast we get so high we love
Portlandia who gives a [__] his uncle
Joey [__]
swinging it smoking it a little water
for the dehydration system to get the
THC burning in your system I'm gonna do
the last of the bad boys you get
whatever you want
you know I love Timmy Holloway he gave
me that my Goomba me and Timmy robbed
the gas station we were in high school
he came to one of the shows and he gave
me that that one in Ozzy Osbourne one
and he's just sent me a Julius Erving on
a rare Julius Erving one with a 16
uniform now with a 60 uniform on with
the ball like this
I don't even bring in the elephant in
the office is so cool yeah [__]
limousines for the feed on it's a
[__] beautiful statue limousine for
the feet are the old converse [__]
with the stripes for high-level I told
you this is the wheel abdullah group we
need [__] around that's the [__] Isis
to send it over here to make you [__]
Oh at the light and also you get shot a
[__] egg Louise Shinobu we [__]
around in luigia Nobu or not Doolittle
grow up they put this [__] together for
you even my eyebrows itchy when your
eyebrows edgy you know shits gonna go
down an ugly wait I'm saying let's do a
couple more bonnets and then you could
go back to the Golden Globes oh look at
the dress she's got on she must be a
Scientologist who gives a buck jack
[Music]
this [__] smoking do labor here
you wanna [__] play you come down
here to the Voodoo Lounge you wanna hell
your body isn't oh it tastes like
pineapple I don't give a [__] when I got
taste like one thing that you understand
me cuz we see the devil here we don't
don't come in here unless you plan on
going deep into the murky waters of the
underworld I brought you a little star
professor not as strong as the red ones
these are the blue ones see with him to
be says do you see do you see these
[Music]
this is wacky taffy this is when you're
going deep you book this outlaw Jimmy
Page LibDem what's-his-name's house for
Maine you people this is a beautiful way
to start the week
you got your goals written you got your
push-ups tomorrow
it's listen yeah all last week that was
[__]
the really starts tomorrow you got to
write your goals tonight you got to do
your push-ups tonight and watch rocky
one the first one today the only one
that's getting your way is you [__] up
do you understand me [__] all that
nonsense let's put this together this is
your year you're sitting there feeling
sorry for yourself
everybody gets [__] taking the
[__] DEET you understand me everybody
the Jews got kicked in the teeth the
Indians got kicked for the deep the
Armenians got kicking the deep boy
you're gonna sit down on the floor with
an ice pack in your mouth [__] no you
gotta get up put on some false teeth cuz
people don't like you walking around
with no [__] teeth and then you gotta
go out there and we bang it out every
[__] day this is your year [__]
it starts tomorrow the night the [__]
January everything else was just a
playground so right off last week
everything starts tomorrow so get the
[__] cigarette smoke twenty dual from
tonight swamp 55 [__] joints beat
that hamburger tonight but your year
starts tomorrow write your [__] goals
and stop [__] feeling [__] sign for
yourself that used to be me under a
bridge life don't like I don't like
nobody like don't like [__] nobody
that's why I get it don't make me
[__] come through the screen and grab
you by the [__] eyeball
something I'm sorry I get emotional
every time I hear this album and now
[__] death is coming your way with
the ocean are you [__] are you [__]
kidding me we're gonna have to do
another bunk in here how deep do we have
to go on a Sunday night you understand
me won't make the [__] will like Jesus
we went deep we're going deep for you
for your [__] little [__] sentence
you understand it oh [__] oh [__] how
many times I Drive up New Yorker reason
to the sound right here I would turn the
heat up there we go [__] uncle Joey's
coming for you [__] that zipper up
you understand me this is it houses of
the holy baby look at this out
look at this now for people on the
inside are you ready for this you know
what this is supposed to be
Joey Alvarado you have to check the
facts either before or after this album
I did sacrifice Robert Plant son
character and they said that he was
sacrificing to the gods right there
let's up we'll have some goofy [__] man
we gotta check out we gotta check out we
gotta check it out
cuz he put the arm with all kids and
[__] they're all kids
[Music]
handling the gods is a book by Led
Zeppelin they talk about a story in
Seattle when they put the octopus up the
chicks [__] or the shark shark a baby
shark up the chicks [__] Led Zeppelin
was up to a different level you
understand me
the only people who caught up the Led
Zeppelin I think were like Guns and
Roses
even Skynyrd the Allman Brothers none of
them Zeppelin had a [__] plane with a
fireplace who the [__] is drawing that
type baby are you kidding me or what
it's Sunday night grab your [__] the
year starts tomorrow tomorrow go to a
[__] kettle bell class what do we do
just do something just to prove yourself
you didn't even if the rest of the year
you're a [__] mutt but you're not
gonna be a mutt you know why cuz
yong-chol Joey Electric [__] let's
do a bong hit and let's call it a night
all right night-night and we have sweet
dreams and I'll see you [__]
tomorrow same bat-time same bat-channel
you ready for another bong hit Lee you
gonna sit there like an orphan what's
the story know his son's name was
Carrick when the carrot plant passed
away I think it was 73 and some [__]
freaking car accident something
something wasn't right
[Music]
you know the car excellent you know what
a car accident this came out in 73 or
something weird you know what happens
when you have a crime scene you know
what that means you have to feel both
hella GWACs if you focus on when you're
Cupid you have to feed it like one and
when you're gonna get red they'll tell
you you gotta feed a big white and you
gotta get the chicken and feel you are
on a corner I had to do it a couple
years ago and surprise I'll cover
chickadee [__] that's the way it goes
down anyway write your goals tonight
remember the power of the pen is a
[__] listen to [__] Jimmy
Page tear this [__] up like he's [__]
old shitty understanding I might even
sit through your song remains the same
perceptor I'm that type of [__]
but I'm happy you showed up the leg you
know I don't see you guys I've missed
the concert
[Music]
that's what Sunday's are made for people
your family a few bong hits hanging out
with Lee and a good guest that's all
that meant a nice show is brought to you
by on the zip recruiter helix sleep and
[__] me on these [__] have a
good night
write your goals the year starts
tomorrow [__] everything else everything
else is background music uncle Joey
loves you thank you for tuning in and
about ten minutes go to youtube.com
slash that dot church right /c / Joey
Diaz all right I'll see you guys in 10
minutes get your [__] together